welcome to the market mode of workshop
this week we're covering paid search and
seven practices that will destroy your
account that's a pretty amazing claim
but with us we have Larry Kim the
founder and CEO of word stream at PPC
search marketing tools company and of
course Brad gettys your faculty chair
for paid search founder of certified
knowledge author of advanced Google
AdWords here at market motives so a few
logistics that are important for us to
be able to make it through our workshop
with the most here and we'll do a little
bit more in introductions in just a
moment this is being recorded it will be
available to market motive members a few
days after the production Larry's been
kind enough to tell us that we can offer
up the the PowerPoint slides as well so
we'll be sure to do that we do have some
guests in our workshop so there's going
to be two poles during the workshop one
in just a moment to help Larry and Brad
customize what they talk about to the
average spend that you have in PPC so
prepare yourselves for that and then in
the middle we're going to put up a poll
just to gauge your interest Larry's kind
enough to share with us and of course he
does have products at his company he's
kind enough I know he won't be pitching
them but I'll probably ask him to share
a little bit of that as we get to the
middle and then of course market motive
makes a business out of providing
up-to-date courses and we'll ask what
your interest is in there so Larry's
going to give us an overview is sharing
a screen right now and then about
midpoint through our call today we're
going to open up the lines for questions
and answers and you can type in
questions and answers to us anytime very
Larry and Brad's presentation and talk
here and we'll try to get to those once
we open up the questions and answers
once we switch over to official time
we'll probably unmute your phone if you
have a question if you do not want us to
unmute your phone or your PC microphone
let us know just say don't don't unmute
me just answer my question okay
otherwise we'll give it a shot because
we love live conversation so because you
can type in questions and answers the
responses to Larry at any time I want to
try it right now for those of you who
can hear our voice go to the right-hand
side of your screen you'll find a
questions window sometimes
questions and answers and I want you to
type in an encouraging message to Larry
right now show us that you're listening
we want to see folks actually open up
that window there we go go there we go
from Graham go Larry from Todd rich wow
great David Satele is here look at that
Joe mark everybody look at this buzz
Ruthie Michael it's going so fast I
can't even keep up with it so thank you
for those encouraging messages and Larry
I think I saw a proposal in there that
you'll have to look at later okay last
27 last two tips for success before i
handed over to Larry close your email
Larry moves quickly I want you to take
at least two take away actions from this
workshop on a notepad or on real paper I
also suggest that you open up a browser
window or follow along with Larry and
try and reach or find what he's teaching
on the flights a great way to start
applying things to make a list for
things that you apply to your daily paid
search campaigns so with that we're
going to do a little bit more speaking
reduction in just a moment but with
Larry it's over to you to show us seven
PPC best practices that will destroy
your account how do you like my little
logo there I made that myself air
protection guaranteed all right so
thanks thanks for that and I'm basically
just to kind of set the stage for what
we're going to talk about today we're
talking about best practices in PPC and
well you know all of them I'm sure are
most certainly sort of written with the
best of intentions you know the problem
is that they very rarely factor into
considerations or the time or the cost
involved with learning and implementing
those kind of best practices and so it's
potentially sort of a big deal if you're
sort of a smaller or medium sized
business you know what you know where
you were that the increased cost in
terms of time or complexity of managing
your accounts after having done these
you know complicated optimizations it
could be pretty pretty substantial and
certainly I've won and guilty for of
doing this I've written many many
articles on super dorky advanced BBC
topics we just aren't you know
we're applicable to small businesses
they just you know I would say it's not
worth the time or effort devote to doing
all this stuff if you have so much other
stuff to do and so basically I'm just
just so we're all on the same page here
I'm going to be talking about SMBs and
small businesses so when I say that just
in my head I'm thinking like companies
spending less than five thousand dollars
per month in ad spend so that's kind of
my definition here what we'll just use
that for the sake of consistency here
alright so just to kind of explore the
point a little bit what I mean why this
here is that you know a paid search
marketer you know who's managing 15
million dollar a month campaign you know
versus I just found this one on I did a
Google search this morning this versus a
small insurance agency based in Boston
you know with a five-hundred-dollar
month budget according to spyfu you know
technically you know all of the best
practices that you read on Search Engine
Land or market motive you know they all
do they apply to accounts both big and
small but you know clearly the larger
advertiser here has much more at stake
or alternatively the smaller advertiser
has a lot less 22 at stake and so the
extent or degree to which advertisers
should be adhering to these you know
different various best practices varies
greatly and so the reason why this
matters I think has to do with a failure
to recognize this can lead to one of two
potential problems here and so the first
has to do with just you know advertisers
getting set up or overwhelmed and then
giving up so you know first personally I
love paid search advertising I think
it's an incredibly powerful you know
tool for growing your business and you
know the problem of Turin is a real
problem like in sort of in terms of
persistence so like the ebb here's a
stat for you the average customer
lifetime on like doing paid search for a
new SMB advertiser small business
advertiser is a is just around five
months and so the challenge here is what
happens is that people just get
overwhelmed and they bade get confused
and they stopped using it
you know all within a span of on average
five months because it's really that
complicated and and the other issue that
cover i'd say maybe ten or twenty
percent of the time is that that smaller
advertiser doesn't give up but rather it
you know takes all takes all this you
know all the different tips and pointers
like so seriously and they end up over
allocating their time investment in paid
search management for example hiring
agencies and you know or even dedicated
people to bring some in-house just
trying to adhere to all these different
best practices which you know definitely
are helpful and you know improve your
account metrics but could potentially
result in negative return on investment
when you consider all the management
costs that you're you're you're
incurring and so you know we're talking
about a balance here in terms of the you
know adverts best practices you know for
spectacle small business owner how much
it's good enough and then the great news
here is that you know there's many many
shortcuts that you can take for small
businesses and you know best practices
you could you can kind of ignore to get
sort of eighty percent of the benefits
with just twenty percent of the work so
that kind of brings me to my agenda
first day which is these best practices
that that you can potentially ignore you
know we're going to talk a little bit
about like how much is good enough and
how that varies based on sort of your
investment in in paid search and we'll
figure out all the different shortcuts
and now brad is on blind here today
he'll be weighing in on all the
different topics that we're talking
about today as well as doing the QA
today so I'm speaking of Brad it's great
to be on a webinar would be Brad it's
been a while so welcome word streamers i
understand it like roughly half of the
people on webinar today are kind of word
streamers because we don't jointly
promoted this event and so that for
those of you who might not be familiar
with Brad he's a you know really smart
educator in the field of paid search
marketing
speaker prolific writer and speaker at
over 100 different events that's like
you know a lot of events a lot of miles
and he's a prolific author about author
of the advanced Google AdWords book and
look for a third edition of that coming
out in stores later this year and he's
also the paid search and structure in
market motive Brad did you want to fail
0 to 4 people everyone Brad's here we'll
get into a fun Q&A throw up but I'm so
fun to be here as usual and talk with
you Larry awesome and my name is Larry
I'm the founder of word stream and it's
just great to be doing this webinar with
the lit with you guys here today now
we've got a you know if you want to be
live blogging you know our official
today just use the hashtag market mode
of in your Twitter tweets and and I have
my phone here so I can I can see that
and I thought we could just start with a
little poll here pull questions to
figure out who's on our call today can
we launch the poll question please
absolutely yep where I'll go ahead and
put the pull up by the way just so you
know probably I kinda ruined it for you
here being so loud we've had four or
five folks just ask if you can get a
little bit louder and what I'll do is
I'll turn my microphone down so I'm not
quite as noisy and hopefully folks can
turn the volume up safely just so Larry
and Brad can i'm going to both head and
put the pull up now just so Larry and
Brad can kind of coach the crew here
appropriately we're going to put up what
is your monthly PPC spin and graham
sends it in pounds that's awesome but
you can use the pole here yeah for those
of you in Europe apologies that we
didn't put euros or pounds on there but
the pull is on your screen go ahead and
click and we'll wait till we get to
about seventy percent of you voting on
this before and then actually Larry if
you don't mind I'll share the results so
everybody can see what the audience pans
out can be so far with those of you
clicking twenty-eight percent or 10,000
and up twenty-seven percent are at the
thousand-dollar level each
month and only eight percent are at zero
so far so we're going to have a few more
of you vote then we'll share so you can
see the you can see the size of the
audience and by the way Larry and Brad
you're not allowed to vote I think
neither one of you really gets onto the
screen somebody say in twenty rubles and
we'll give Matt will get the hashtag to
you in just a moment here and waiting
for just a few more of you to click on
the pole and then i'll go ahead and
close it and share it and that way
everybody will see what we're looking at
and and larry you'll be able to
customize what we're talking about to
this crowd okay to more clicks and then
we'll go ahead and close there's one and
there's two and here we go okay so i'll
put i'll share this put it on the screen
maybe you can see that right now it
looks like a 10,000 plus twenty nine
percent Larry can you see the results
there I can't but if you could just talk
to her you got it under ten under ten
thousand under 10,000 you're looking at
a total of about let's see 47 and 15
plus another ten thirty and the majority
of people probably seventy percent of
the people are under 10,000 here and
then you have twenty-nine percent that
are 10,000 and up so fairly well spread
to that group there and I thank you for
voting on them and Larry's back over to
you alright alright thanks so on to the
best practices or worse practices
whatever you want to call them the first
the first one I have on my left here is
this notion of always being always being
testing and so what does that mean
basically do you really need to be
constantly constantly testing stuff you
know how much testing is enough and guys
one of the things that one of neat
things award streams we work with so
many thousands of advertisers that I'm
able to pull up some data here and you
know earlier this morning like students
research into figuring out sort of
what's the breakdown of AD impressions
according to the number of ads
and so to do this I looked at a few
thousand accounts and kind of tried to
figure out what what the typical
distribution is and so you know as far
as small businesses are concerned like
the accounts of people spending you know
less than 5,000 a month typically what
you see is an 85 5 split what that means
is that roughly 85 of the ad impressions
in a small business advertisers account
or comfort are from just five percent of
the ads and so when I look at the
typical size of a small business AdWords
account like this is some research that
I've pulled from from a cover of just
last year you know on average these
accounts they have what do they look
like they look like two campaigns 9a
groups just 18 ads and so that five
percent equates to really one ad on
average soaking up the lion's share of
the the ad impressions and so I was just
thinking here you know in order to kind
of save time I get it you have other
things to do or orient other it responds
all this is you know you want to do do
everything and so to save save some time
you can actually get by with sort of
having one great ad and you know the
rest of you guys could could you know be
you could get by with them being
mediocre I supposed to say that you
couldn't um you know optimize those
other ads to I'm just saying there's
like pretty steep diminishing returns
for the typical small business so I
thought we could talk a little bit about
you know how to write this one great ad
and and basically how great should it be
and so again I did some research free
guys this morning about you know what
are typical click-through rates and of
course as you know click through rates
on ads they vary greatly according to
the prominence of the ad positioning so
for example if you're in the first spot
you would expect to get a much higher
click-through rate than if you're in the
fifth or sixth spot by the world which
you have much lower spot but here on
this table for you today
I just crunched some numbers I'm trying
to give you a sense for like you know
how great would your great ad have to be
and I'm kind of setting the bar very low
here because I want to make sure that
it's achievable if I'm only going to ask
for one of them and I want it to be
great and basically what I'm showing you
is the median click your rate in terms
of like like that's important
measurement of sort of add relevancy and
I just wanted to show the show here that
there's a great deal of variance in
terms of like you know the standard
deviation on these ads are fairly high
like seven percent standard deviation or
whatever so the idea here is that yeah
you can shoot to the average that's the
median value but you could also try to
get ads that were sort of in the in the
best fifteen percent or the best five
percent or even the best one percent of
advertisers and if you're sort of it the
best fifteen percent then then you're
you're roughly double the average if
you're the best five percent you roughly
three times above the average and if
you're the best the top 1% of
advertisers with anything that you can
actually be six times the median and so
just some tables in terms of the inverse
of how great they need to be and as for
how how could you kind of get an ad that
had this kind of metrics without taking
forever you know I think one of the
really cool shortcuts to sort of this
upper middle class of ads is to use this
technique called dynamic keyword
insertion and I'm just going to ask Brad
if you could kind of share with our
audience on kind of how this works and
what it's all about sure so dynamic
keyword insertion is the ability to put
a variable at in this case the the
variable is the brace the keyword colon
um what shows up in other cases of in
close the brace in and when you write an
ad this way the key word in your ad
group that caused your ad to be
displayed is put into the ad instead of
whatever you would write typically so if
you had in this case your
words were red couches blue couches
green couches and somewhat short short
couch the ad but automatically changed
to get prices on red couches so when
you've got unorganized accounts or
larger groups of ad groups and not a lot
of granular breakdown this is a great
way of increasing CTR for for smbs so
thanks for that description I just
wanted to show how dynamic keyword
insertion ads perform on average so
remember how I was showing you Brad
earlier the the the table is sort of
like what the average click-through rate
is and sort of what would it be to be
the top 15% of ads the top 5% of ads
which are like three times the average
or the top 1% which is like six times
the average I call the top 1% I call
those guys unicorns just just for fun
but basically I wanted to see kind of on
average how to ads with then using
dynamic keyword insertion perform on
average compared to our ads that do not
and so what you can see here is that in
terms of the relative frequency of these
ads making them into into above average
click-through rates and or even the top
15 or top 5% of ads you have a very good
chance of kind of getting a not a top
not like a top two or top 3% kind of AD
but you know a decent upper-middle-class
kind of AD just by by using this little
trick the dynamic keyword insertion in
your ads and in that that can be very
very helpful as for the top five or top
1% what happens if you notice there
there's like an inversion happening
there so what it's saying is that as you
you know given to these really really
awesome ads to get like 20 30 40 percent
click-through rates those are less
likely to be you know yeah kind of
employing dynamic keyword insertion
they're more likely to be using like
just really solid copy writing and
talking about your your guarantee or
you're off
or whatever but you know if the goal is
just to get to good enough I think
dynamic keyword insertion is is your is
your meal ticket to upper middle class
for ads just 22 important disclaimer so
that was the that it doesn't tend to
produce like the stellar you know what
top five or top one percent and the
other disclaimer is sometimes end up in
these situations i call these adwords
jackpots because it kind of reminds me
of hitting a row of lucky sevens in
Vegas you know jackpot I just hit a row
of big data solutions so you got
sometimes you gotta do searches on the
keywords and trying to make sure that
your your stuff is still a little bit
differentiated and that you're talking
about you know your your core value
proposition and all the stuff but but
with those caveats you know I think you
know should you be always be testing
absolutely sure but you know if you
don't have all day just focus on that
one gray dad you'll get most of the
benefit if you're a small business and
and and and just leverage this dynamic
keyword insertion to to to get a decent
showing out of gates anything to add on
this or comments Brett no I the only
comment I would say is the large you get
the less you want to rely on it because
usually there's an inverse relationship
with DKI and click the rate versus
conversion rates or the better your DK I
ctrs the worse your conversion rates get
um for larger companies for smaller ones
this is spot on yep and a quick question
from the audience here too are seen as
how well does dynamic keyword insertion
work when it's in the description lines
um it still works well and in fact in
those jackpot ads that are Larry the
showed when you're in those situations I
prefer going to use it move it to the
description lines and make a headline
that does pop I didn't either by the way
Larry just folks are dying to hear you
Larry they're asking if you could speak
up just a little bit probably 15 20
people are saying they can't hear you at
all sure sure sure I just saying I
didn't I didn't run the numbers on on
like how it differs depending on where
where the positioning is of the dynamic
keyword insertion unfortunately I don't
have a straight answer for that one
right now but would let's move on to
number two which is a very fundamental
best practice that that's been kind of
ingrained in all of our heads since you
know you know you know fundamental 101
of a paid search which is to always
separate your search and display
campaigns right you when you create a
new campaign in AdWords it asks you what
type of companies you want to create is
it a display campaign or search campaign
or both and the end the best practice
has always been to separate the two so
what if I were to tell you here and this
is morpheus here who's saying one out of
five businesses small businesses use the
Google Display Network meaning eighty
percent of you guys if you're a small
business eighty percent of them aren't
leveraging or tapping into the power of
this display network and the reason is
because it's just it's just a lot of
work it's a lot of complexity it's a lot
of new things that they need to learn
and so I think that's really unfortunate
because you know when I look at again
some numbers that I pulled this morning
when I look at different average cost
per clicks of course across the
different networks sort of a google
search Network versus the Display
Network what what I find is that you can
potentially get tremendously cheaper
clicks on the Display Network versus the
search Network look at jobs in education
like a dollar eighty was not the average
that I computed this morning versus
adults but 34 cents for the Display
Network so like that's almost like a
fifth of the cost and an other
competitive industries like finance you
know business and industrial there's
there's value to be had on the display
network in terms of like just lower
prices in in competitive verticals and
similarly I rents numbers on on typical
conversion rates and just to see like
you know how does display
convert in comparison to search now
search is still the king in terms of
like they have an overall better
conversion rate because there's a lot of
intent with those searches but display
wasn't all that far behind so if you
look across all the industries but the
number that I ran this morning where it
was showing that you know display was
just you know a point behind so that's
roughly twenty percent less and there
were actually a few industries such as
travel and autos and vehicles where you
can see that the conversion rate on
display ads is even higher than the
conversion rate for google search and
and why is that I think it's because
travel and autos I think those are like
cool products that you kind of want to
see in an image you know as opposed just
a text ad so so the prep that's why they
they do a little bit better so when you
combine sort of the average cost per
click and the average conversion rates i
can give you kind of a rough idea for
what you might expect to pay for you
know for cost fraction like your your
cost per lead or cost per sale for
different industries and basically you
can see that they're very comparable and
in many cases lower on the display
network because of those two factors
that we're talking about the the lower
cost per click and you know comparable
conversion rates and so essentially
there's a even more benefits so word
stream my own business like we we use
AdWords to do to do marketing of our
software products and in addition to you
know just getting our ads up there we
got a ton of other secondary benefits
beyond just cost per conversion you know
we had a huge impact on brand recall so
we started running display and
remarketing ads and then here's what
you're looking at on the screen is
literally my google analytics it's the
it's the direct traffic so people who
typed in you know wwe.com directly to
went directly to my website without
going through say like an article
or an ad and you can see that when we
turned it on we had a huge increase in
brand recall and i think that there's a
lot of benefits for small businesses to
use the remarketing in terms of helping
with the conversion rates it's also
ideal for advertisers who are perhaps
you know advertising in a smaller
geographic area perhaps they're one of
challenges is a little impression volume
on the on the search network and so
recently I was really interested to
learn that just a few months ago a
google introduced this new new kind of
campaign type they replace the old one
with a new thing called display select
and it's actually the default option and
so it's saying what what they're saying
here is that it it's a little bit more
picky and more selective in terms of you
know how it displays the the display ads
and it tries to actually compete with
the cost per actions of your search
campaigns and on average they're telling
us that it generates you know fifteen
percent more more sales at a comparable
cost cost for action on average and so
you know when I want to think about you
know the challenges and the realities of
like being in the trenches of running a
small business and also wanting to get
more sales you know should I be
separating my search and display
campaigns you know absolutely if you
have the time and expertise to do that
but if but if you didn't I certainly
wouldn't fault you for you know giving
out this new campaign type a try for a
week and see see how that goes any
thoughts or dad there right I don't
because no one I work with us willing to
be a guinea pig to try it out or they've
already separated out display and so
they're not gonna take a step backwards
so I actually haven't tried this out yet
i'm waiting for the first guinea pig
well we work with a lot of like these
smaller city guys and
this is a view it as a quick win for for
the small business and generally what
happens is that like for the you know
handful maybe dozen or so cases that
I've been involved with is that it it
provides her at the motivation to then
to then see like like oh yeah this is
something interesting kind of almost
like a stepping stones into it to
motivating them to do more work but but
yeah but that's sort of what we're
seeing here okay lot see back coming in
from folks to in there we see buzz say a
lot of smbs do only one or the other but
Devon's saying they've tried it out and
it works really well a lot of questions
as to whether people should use display
select any feedback on that yet that's
exactly what I'm talking about here
that's the new campaign type of the
display it's this one here a search
network with display select and I'm
saying look if you if you already have
done the work of separating your
campaigns between search and display
then there's no need to do this because
that would be a step backwards but if
you're like most small businesses like
and I'm telling you eighty percent of
them in that spin range like spending
less than five thousand a month eighty
percent of them are not tapping into the
power of the Google Display Network
which is like the biggest ad network on
the planet you know you know for those
people if the reason is because they're
not using it because of not having
enough time or too much effort then I
would definitely be thinking about just
trying it out and seeing how that that
goes because uh there's fingers so much
potential there excellent feedback
thanks and folks I do see the questions
Brad I'm going to move you to organizer
just so you can see some of the
questions if you don't mind and maybe
just filled a few of those as they're
coming in okay sure all right are there
any that we need to address right now
there's a good number of them I think
you'd go ahead and stay on we're going
to go ahead and go back and see if
people still have the question once
you've finished with the presentation
and if they do we'll
bring it up live otherwise we'll try and
handle it as a stream and keep you on
track Larry so moving along so what's a
good click-through rate for my small
business or any metrics for this matter
and so you know I've read a lot of
articles where they say you need to get
you know this percent or that percent or
whatever and one of the challenges is
that like I was saying earlier it's
really and it's really dependent on how
much you're investing in paid search I
mean you don't have to kill yourself to
get like a you know five percent
click-through rate if you're only
investing you know fifty dollars in
search or whatever so the solution here
is to use sort of these contextualized
benchmarks and for this I just want to
show you something that I developed here
it's called the let me just see here
it's called the AdWords performance
grader so this is a free tool you can
just absolutely free no obligation or
whatever you just go to www.google.com
tools out there it it grades your key
performance metrics like click to rate
like quality score like conversion rates
it grades them on a curve okay so what
it's doing is it seems like you're
nineteen percent here okay what it's
doing is it's coming up with these
metrics based on looking at comparables
so it's looking at other companies in
your industry so like say you were like
in business and industrial or in travel
and tourism like it looks at companies
in your industry but also within your
budget range so in this case the guy is
spending 1821 euros per month on average
and so the the the scoring in terms of
the metrics are all relative to other
comparable advertisers spending roughly
the same amount and within the same
industry and so you can see for example
I just I won't go through the whole
report but you can see it like this idea
of quality score
you know this guy has an average of 2.6
well this this curve here is what we see
for other people in in the in that
industry and that size of spent and so
we're able to kind of really
contextualize those numbers and in this
case stop Larry what's the URL of a
greater can you we've got a bunch of
people asking we're trying to find it
it's WWE extreme calm flash google dash
Edward okay we'll go ahead and put that
into the message in here so everybody
can paste it in and take a look at the
same thing and if you look at your chat
window you'll see that there thanks
Larry yeah what's great about this is
just it's providing you sort of like the
context so like you know in boxing you
wouldn't have liked I don't know the
heavyweight champion guy you know Geico
or whatever boxing against sort of the
little insurance guys spending fifty
dollars a month you know on its local
insurance business like that would be
silly that's why they have different
weight classes and so what's really
interesting about this tool is that were
able to benchmark your performance on
more of a kind of a more level playing
field if you will in terms of like
having you you see how much how will
your doing against other people with
similar amount of investment dollars
it's ad spend at stake or being being
invested here's one an interesting one
it has to do with account activities
like how much work is enough that's a
great question but people always want to
know am i doing enough in my AdWords
account and so what this is doing its
saying well this guy he's done you know
10 ads or 30 you know campaigns but you
know for other people in this industry
who are spending 2,000 pounds a month
it's kind of on the low side in terms of
his his the amount of effort that he's
putting into managing the account so I'm
not going to go over the whole report
but as you can see the key what I'm
trying to say here is now when you see
those benchmarks and stuff like this
even the benchmarks that I provide you
know first of all don't be discouraged
because a lot of times these benchmarks
are
are based on kind of like expert you
know top one percenter type achievement
but but if you are going to use these
benchmarks then consider using these
sort of comparable metrics within your
industry you know that our index based
on your your company size anything to
add to your bread Brad may have himself
muted there or he's completely absorbed
in the AdWords grading tool well I had
me to myself because I was answering
questions and I have a keyboard that's
not the quietest thing in the world um
so to know I don't but what I want to
take like 15 seconds to explain because
I see a lot of questions office is
conversion versus click um so when when
Larry says like that's someone going to
your website from the search result or
from a display ad if someone does an
action on this site like fill out a form
call your company buy a product that's a
conversion so when when back in the
display section when Larry was kind of
showing click through rate CPC and
conversion rates because kind of showing
is CPC's were cheaper for display you
paid for a click and conversion rates
were a little bit less for display than
search but because the CPC's are cheaper
the cost per action that what you pay to
get something to fill out a form or take
some action is roughly the same as
depending on industry for those two it's
all right that answers like a third of
the questions i was looking at so that
would be useful thing that toss out
there um benchmarking is good I didn't
catch it all Larry but the the words
from greater tool is a great place for
SMEs to kind of get a good look so um I
would actually suggest everyone
everyone's got us more accountant need
some ideas go try it out it's actually
really useful for that Iowa got to know
all right so our next one here is has to
do with the use of something called
broad match keywords and so I just your
Brad can you explain for audience sort
of just we're all on the same page what
do they mean by broad match keyword
and this notion of match types sure so
the the match type is essentially how
close it related your keyword is in your
account to the search query with someone
types in a search engine before your ad
can be displayed so like with with exact
match um google wants the search query
and your keywords to be really really
close so in this example formal shoes
you could you could be shown for a
formal shoe a singular or a misspelling
but you wouldn't be shown for formal
sandals but both those words have to be
in the query and nothing else has to in
the query I'm phrase match is how the
same thing is exact except there can be
additional words on either side but they
must be in that same order um with these
by the way if that seems confusing to
you it's because Google has something
known as close variation match which is
on by default which basically says exact
match by default does not have to be the
actual users clearly can be missed
spelling or a singular plural so my pet
which is a change from the past you can
switch that setting so it's the exact
same thing um modified broad match is
one of my favorite match types it
essentially says especially for small
businesses um I basically says I don't
care what order the user types of
keywords in I don't care if a user
misspells it or uses a singular versus a
plural keyword all i care is these words
that i put in my account and i put a
plus on it from to denote these are
really important to me are in their
search query um and so that would be the
the modified bob of plus formal plus
shoes if you look at your query and say
i don't we sell shoes but i don't care
for evening shoes dress shoes sandals
whatever then you could do formal plus
shoes which basically means shoes has to
be in that query or singular version but
i don't care if it's formal or black
shoes and then broad match is basically
saying anything google deemed similar
you can show your ads for so formal
shoes could show for like black sandals
further well the shoot i ether and
formal as
waxaa color formal shoes and so broad
gets a little broad in my opinion but I
really like modify broad for a lot of a
lot of reasons what do you use for small
businesses Larry do you like broader
modified broad well I mean I will that's
a great question Brad so I looked at me
I looked at some accounts this morning
and i was looking at kind of getting a
sense for how much impression volume
gets accrued to what type of match types
now in Google in general something like
seventy percent of of the you know
impression volume goes to keywords set
to broad match but on small business in
particular like just the company
spending less than 5,000 a month on paid
search I was pretty surprised to see
that ninety percent of the impression
volumes were being accrued to keywords
that were set by the advertisers to a
broad match and so you know to me that
it's it's it's a kind of a sign that
says that you know there's potentially a
lot of volume out there that you could
be you're missing out on it if you're
not using broad match for this
particular and I did not differentiate
between broad match and modified broad
match like there's no there's no
difference in terms of the type can I
casa fault there is this a chicken me I
guess you though because it's something
like and I forget the actual number but
it's something like seventy percent of
all queries on Google do not have an
exact match variation in any account
anyone the world it's the vast majority
queries so is the broad match getting
queries because exact doesn't exist or
as broad match getting queries because
um there's just so many query variations
out there any sales on like it I just
think that as far as our you know small
business listeners are concerned the
point here is just many an article has
been written about the dangers and and
the problems
associated with being excessively broad
using broad match but i would say that
like I don't know the answer to your
question Brad but the key takeaway I
think is just that there are some some
benefits specifically for smbs when it
comes to broad match you can reduce the
clutter in terms of like you know not
having to have a ton of stuff to
managing your account you can certainly
you don't have to spend a ton of time on
keyword research here research is
regularly one of the top three biggest
time sucks of a paid search in all of
our surveys you know it's really great
for local businesses who it where
there's like not a ton of search volume
on the keywords that they're interested
but all this comes of a price and that
price is just the control like the lack
of you're losing some some control over
over you know you're turning over the
keys to Google in terms of how you want
your ad you're as short but yeah I don't
know did you have anything to add there
right um no I just my if you're if you
are worried about modify broad matches I
don't modify broad I find converts just
as well as phrase match and you don't
have to deal with all these all these
additional things so I think it's a
great match site for us on these to use
I was goes one step further like for the
small business that I work with I even
tell them just forget about phrase and
and exact match and and just you know
exclusively if it just exclusively used
modified broad match because this is
such a time-saver for them I don't know
if you would agree with that or not but
like this is for the smaller businesses
ya know on for smaller businesses I have
no problem with that at all especially
if you've got lack of either conversion
tracking or lack of enough conversion
tracking data to add the proper in exact
matches modified broad scrapes Allah so
that brings me to our this one here
which is to optimize for conversions now
I mean we we run poll questions all the
time on like what's the most important
KPIs and now what do you optimize for
and no surprise you know optimizing for
conversions always
so it is number one way to to manage
your bids but you know I was supposed to
change that slide picture but the
challenge here is with small businesses
like if you've got a five hundred
dollar-a-month or five foot five
thousand dollar arm of budgets then you
know first of all out of the gates to
fifty percent of the small businesses
don't have conversion tracking turn on
it's just it's just very difficult for
them baby you know they're all their
website is run by some guy like a like a
your brother of mine you don't have a
good relationship with that guy you
don't want to bother him or something
you know it's not it's not the same and
so sometimes you know they're just not
able to get this thing working and so
then then you're in trouble
alternatively you know there's another
challenge comes of all the time is that
you have kind of small numbers of
sporadic convert conversions like you
might go a week with like one or five
conversions and it's just not a ton of
data to use to to optimize your your
bids and so for this I would certainly
you know in these situations would
consider just optimizing for clicks like
the cost per clicks like going after the
cheapest clicks or or even just
optimizing by click to rate it looks so
like bidding more for the key words that
appear to be resonating like that appear
to be generating more more interest
anything to answer that Brad I know you
mentioned yet a lot to say about like
out of how to work with these situations
I the other data point I like to add and
I didn't catch our nursing as also
answering questions so but I'm the other
point that that I like to add to this
because you've got sporadic data is
bounce rates or time on site and
attaching google analytics into AdWords
so that you have this intermediate
number so if you've got 50 clicks in one
hundred percent bounce rate it's
probably not a good good click or good
keyword where if you've got you know 50
clicks on a 20-percent bounce rate and
no conversions hey those are great
interactions and so I find if you've got
sporadic conversions that using the
panel
linux as intermediate signals to the
quality of a traffic will still let you
do some optimization it may be for
quality over actual conversions but at
least it's on a number that shows you're
getting the correct type of visitors to
your site I agree hundred percent so I
just wanted to add some encouragement
here in terms of like you know if you're
feeling Wow with paid search a lot to
learn and then there's a lot of stuff
that I need to be doing here but the
reality is that the bar is lower than
you might think and so again some
research based on you know what's the
typical account look like in terms of
you know what does it look like and you
can see that again it's a to campaign
Niagara 18 add text now 212 keywords
we're not talking like I mean this is
doable as we can do this and and in
terms of like how active people are you
know like fifty three percent of
advertisers only touch their account
once every quarter only one percent of
them you know do even one change in the
last quarter and less like three months
and so like the idea here is that you
know you got it's just about adopting a
workflow kind of where you pace yourself
and then you just you just say look I'm
going to just slow and steady wins the
race i'm going to just focus on like one
thing this week spending 20 minutes a
week on your paid search accounts that
would put you in the top 1% of most
active small business accounts in the
world so the bar is low and the prize is
your fro taking if you can just you know
motivate yourself to do this kind of
stuff I think I've their breath nope no
bats permits so we've been talking a
little bit about you know how best
practices you know are impacted by your
budget by how how much you spend and how
the degree of
you know compliance with the best
practice is completely dependent on you
know how much your you're investing in
paid search and so essentially we're
talking about the acceptor but the the
cost of PPC management I just wanted to
share a little bit of how I think about
the problem here so like for example
suppose you're spending you know between
a dollar and nine hundred ninety nine
dollars u.s. dollars per month on on
Adwords and and these ranges are
approximate so it's so like I don't mean
it to be a hard cut off or anything but
just as a kind of a general bobble
ballpark number if you're spending like
fifty dollars or hundred dollars on paid
search you know you you should be using
AdWords Express I mean this thing it's
just odd it's like the autopilot AdWords
where you just swipe your credit card
and it writes your ads for you it
manages things the reason is is because
you know if you're spending 10 hours on
managing that account that's like far
like that's way out of whack in terms of
like the value of your time so much more
than than the fifty dollars or whatever
you're spending on AdWords per month and
so that's a pretty simple automatic
pilot solution that has literally no
management costs associated with it you
know where when you're in the middle
range of anywhere from like a thousand
and twenty five hours a month and then
this is against approximate numbers it
doesn't have to be you know the exact
1,000 25,000 well then you're kind of in
this area where it were you know you're
doing the work yourself or using tools
such as were stream or any of the other
tools out there in terms of the cost is
just the cost of your time and and the
software products you know they're
anywhere from like two to five hundred
dollars a month in terms of the
management costs and then once you get
into the bigger budget ranges that's
when you start considering like maybe
bring bring in like a dedicated person
to do this kind of work or hiring an
agency which you know dedicated person
might cost you here in Boston it's
around 65,000 a year and yeah if it's an
agency anywhere from ten to fifteen
percent of the ad spend is pretty
typical but it is the reason is because
at those levels of ad spend you can
definitely justify the additional
expense
because of the the there's a lot of
return on investment to be had on those
ad dollars so that's how I think about
the challenge of you know the cost of
PPC management and how to go about
allocating money to manage it anything
to add their bread the other thing I
would add is is that they're even at a
10-grand range there are times an agency
is a good solution if you're not going
to manage it yourself then that an
agency can be good at lower numbers but
you get to a point you're going to spend
you know twenty percent of your spin on
management but it's if you're going to
spend 20 grand a month and never look at
it then you're better off giving an
agency fifteen percent of its spend who
will but some of that not these are
these are pretty good numbers overall to
to benchmark things from excellent by
the way just as a point of order Larry I
know that we're going to lose a lot of
people right at the top of the hour
that's in about six minutes we may want
to go ahead and get to some of the
questions and answers as soon as
possible put up a poll so we can get
some feedback from folks as well that's
over I think over 100 questions that
have come in so we want to make sure i
get to those as quickly as we can Brad
and I are typing answers as fast as we
can Larry I'll leave it to you legit
expect the most of the time and Brad and
Larry if you're willing to stay after
the hour some of you who are willing to
stick around we'll try and answer those
questions as well Larry awesome so just
recapping that that's a lot flight
actually you know the best practices
that we talked about well I would you
summarize your time isn't free and so
you know sometimes good enough is good
enough for for small businesses and and
you should be thinking about some the
shortcuts that we talked about today you
know key thing is just don't don't be
discouraged don't give up you know it's
you you can be successful here with just
a little bit of time and effort okay so
is it okay if I mentioned something
about my products your this point you go
ahead Larry yeah so just wanted to give
you a pitch on Ward stream what do we do
it's a paid search management platform
for small businesses so what do we sell
we sell something called a 20 minute PPC
work week and as its name suggests it's
just like it's a stool that kind of
finds the 10 things to do in your
account this week and it literally takes
20 minutes to do like finding negative
keywords or optimizing bids or deleting
keywords and it's a very simple software
for for people who don't have all day to
work on on their paid search campaigns
one of the new features that we just
really expect it has to do with hosting
and creating landing pages so member i
always saying like fifty percent of
people don't even have the conversion
tracking turned on and that's because
like the complexities of managing
landing pages so we have like you know
complete you know landing page creation
and hosting software tools so it's fine
just open up the pole for for audience
even thanks for so much for busting in
here we've got a couple offers here did
you want to read off the different
options and launch a poll absolutely i
put the pole up there Larry and Brad you
don't get to vote the poll just gives
you a chance to tell us what your
interest is and Larry's been kind enough
to teach it just gratis for us and offer
this for everybody who's attending and
so I be awesome if you could let them
know if you have interest in either a
live demo of the word stream PPC advisor
or a one-on-one walkthrough with the
AdWords great or that some of you have
been clicking on a Teresa I know you
have some questions on that that will
try and answer in just a moment in
addition brad has been teaching with
market moda for some time now he takes a
coached course a master course and then
we have a self-paced course for large
team sometimes we have thousands going
through at any one time but the coach
course is special for a limit of 20
people per quarter and if you have
interest in market mode of getting back
to you with some information on that
just go ahead and click and let us know
and of course you can also tell us hey
no need I just like the free training
yes that works so we'll leave that up
for a moment and then what we're going
to do is a lot of you have been asking
lots of questions and will call on you
specifically if you have multiple
answer questions in there and give Brad
and Larry a chance to answer you
specifically it's a great chance to get
some feedback from experts who spend
their time building tools and best
practice processes for a wide range
market so far we have how many people
have taken the polls so far about forty
five percent go ahead and get the rest
of you just click on one of those and
then we'll move it open and buzz we get
it you're in starbucks don't unmute me
right right on there we're not going to
hear all those orders coming across
absolutely fine yeah actually this I
gotta say Brad I've not seen a more
interactive crowd in a long time this is
a great group of people asking great
questions and we're going to try to get
to those in just a moment for those of
you who can go ahead and click on that
pole in the meantime Brad can you still
see the questions do you want to read
some of those out loud and see if we can
get get some answers for those sure sure
so let me hop in here and um this is
apple from bus um well hey Larry the big
question actually this was asked a few
times when you did those numbers for the
display network information were they
display only or do they include
remarketing information it's all all
bacon if I didn't it was just all the
display okay so it's not so do you have
any idea like a percentage that that was
remarketing if it was you know 10 or 50
I mean any any rough rough range I don't
have a number off the top of my head but
what I can say is that remarketing is
really the low-hanging fruit of display
and like that's like you know you just
put on your room remarketing code and
kick up your feet and let the money kind
of role in saying is that like that's so
that is the way to make your display
like work way better so I would imagine
it's a good amount of that but I don't
have some exact number sorry I see one
common here that says with no analyst so
let's play network and that's not true
there's you get all the image display
network you want um via Adwords or via
analytics
of some of these look like two
continuations of questions that either
Michael or I answered earlier so there's
not full context all the time but let's
see here are all a good question okay so
here's a question so at the end weary
people want to know should be separate
out display should they use the new
system um can you just I know you my sis
can you touching that one more time
what's the best way to handle the
display select items if you're not
currently using Display Network at all
then at least try it out okay if you're
already using display then there's no
need to use this okay and let's see here
we have a lot of good comments ah link
link link link oh you are a greater
length lot of questions so great link
wow Mike you're not kidding i'm like
halfway to the questions here um and
Larry why your yeah there's the greater
URL um it's called the AdWords greater
if you just go to google and google
adwords greater each be the first thing
on the list all right so here we go so i
I've been in e-commerce for 13 years
mostly SEO starting to get into sem and
wondering if there is a way to grab
order totals for conversions like if
aspect of a customer spends 100 hours of
technology click so essentially with
adwords can you get the actual
conversion numbers from that particular
user or check out like a value trackers
are we thinking bread value track GA
integration i read the question but the
answer is yes there's actually several
ways to do it so it's if you could use
analytics and imported into Adwords you
can also use google's conversion tracker
they've got a variable you can put in it
it's wow that sounds confusing it's
actually not that hard
um Larry here's a question on your
greater tool that came a couple times um
if someone's got an MCC account how do
they get to the AdWords grader so they
log in to that individual account or can
they go to the MCC you can use the MCC
what I'll do is it'll just say okay he's
logged in with an MCC account can you
pick the account that you want to grade
so you'll have to run a report on like
you'll have it's like a two step process
if you use at MCC or if it's not
attempted it doesn't even ask that step
okay um so here's on the question for
you should you have an ad group of the
exact match and modify broad or should
you separate out a groups by matts type
yeah I think that's like for the small
businesses that I work with I think
that's overkill I think that adds a lot
of you know complexity in terms of
management's I think that there isn't a
heck of a lot of difference like Google
is making exact match and phrase match
their kind of making them work more
similarly like they used to be a bigger
bigger difference but but those are
their kind of converging and so you know
I think it's kind of one of those areas
where it's it's potentially easy just
take a shortcut I don't know what do you
think bread I was really nice question
I've got my own oh yes that's got my own
question um for small accounts I agree
it's overkill way overkill um for larger
accounts it's if you've got a really
massive account it's actually useful to
put them together as well um uh if
you've got a mid-sized account i should
like put them in different campaigns
like one campaigns modified broad you're
trying to find words that really convert
well when you find them you move into
different campaign and exact match
higher daily budgets really watching the
conversion so i think that goes directly
to management time and what you can
reasonably accomplish yeah excellent i
have an idea of just for logistics here
because there's so many good questions
there's a few people a lot of people
actually have stayed after the hour and
let's switch to a system where if you
raise your hand and
mechanism to raise your hand we're going
to go ahead and unmute you and allow you
to summarize your questions for both
Brad and Larry and I think that's a
great way to may focus on the folks who
have stuck around here and by the way
for those of you who must leave if you
do have to go now go ahead and put in
something that you think we could do
better or something that you're
particularly enjoyed and I know that
both word stream and market moda will
follow up and you can ask your questions
of the people who reach out as well but
I'm going to scan right now for raised
hands and I see Graham is here so got a
raised hand Graham your life go ahead
and ask your question okay and Graham
may not have been prepared for me to do
that it's soap will go down and check
out any others and I have I'm going to
try and pronounce this as a Quanah quano
we're going to unmute you I do have a
question for red in her leg and again
I'm surprising people i think with this
that's never one off guard yeah it's
okay i mean i think most of the market
mode of crowd knows this is how it works
you're gonna get asked if you ask a
question Craig I've been music you do
you have a question for Bradford oh yeah
I do and Craig them from Ireland and I
work in the online gambling nish so
we're actually a bingo site and my
question is we spend a bit of hundred
tears and pound monthly and most of our
traffic and conversions come via brands
other people brands but obviously our
quality score is very low because we're
not really targeted is there any way to
increase the quality score on brands
keywords brands that you don't have
right so you're you're yeah well they do
yet it will be competitors a named the
best you can do is make landing pages
that are comparison pages that compare
you to the other brand because that way
the pages might be relevant but from a
click-through rate standpoint really
because you can't use D care of brand so
it'll get you a lot of trouble um of
course yeah it's really all about trying
to get those I testing up but if you
break cloudy scores of five or six
another person's brain
and when the brands are high intense
brand arm you're doing pretty good okay
and if I'm a woman other question
possible go ahead um yes so the quad
Cosper clicks in our industry raised
from between about 80 pound to 160 pound
per click however we're not willing to
really put our max cost-per-click
extremely high would you recommend
putting the costs are the max
cost-per-click hired and google's
estimate for first and just seeing how
it goes like testing it or kind of just
go ahead we're going I would go here go
and I in industries where we're Google
suggesting you know hundreds of 200
pounds of click and you do the backwards
Matthew say wow they've gotta like spent
a thousand dollars a month to ever make
that even then i would i would go based
upon your math because there are people
paid a thousand or click yeah and it's
it most industries can't absorb that
profitably and it's usually not worth it
outside of some very specific instances
okay no problem so just layer if you
have anything larry feel free to chime
in i know these are usually not the
accounts you do a lot with uh you know
or i would just like maybe have you
tried to display network at all like
when you talk about like cost per clicks
that high I wonder if like you know yeah
I haven't even with Google in a out of
meeting with Google in Dublin last month
and they're chatting with us about doom
Display Network is currently gambling's
not really allowed on it but they said
there is ways around it so yeah hoping
to get that done soon what they come on
industry when google's helping you get
around their own rules yeah alright
thanks what I scrag whatever idea we
have it's a sometimes we've got
customers and these kind of like you
know gambling or other kind of those
types of industries and I heard that the
restrictions are a lot less on being so
I ok I think about like yeah but if
you're in Ireland Bing is like half a
percent market share
yes nothing perfect thanks guys no
worries all right Matt you have a
question on search display select and
whether you can turn that on your life
hello yep we're here okay you didn't say
my name I think are you talking to my
grave go yep okay oh hey everybody um we
have lots of campaigns that are set to
search and we've dabbled with the
Display Network but we end up turning
off just those straight display
campaigns is it just as simple as a
setting where we turn on a search
campaign to become a search Network
display select yes campaign type but but
so it's just to just pop into the
settings and so if I do the test that
you would selected we're like run it for
a week I'd be able to go backwards and
turn it off if necessary yep okay now I
know one thing is uh you know if you had
ads like image ads to run you you would
have better performance and if you're
using text ads and so you know there is
some tools and AdWords called the
display ad builder it's like these tools
that kind of templates for building some
some you know immediately like a you
know decent image ads and stuff you
could invest a few minutes in trying to
call us and was some creative to run
without you you would definitely see
that in the results okay that answers my
question thanks very much awesome thanks
Matt now Chris you've got a question
here about grabbing order totals from
clicks go ahead my question is I'm in
the cellular market where clicks can be
expensive and profit margins are low so
if I'm teen first link for somebody
quite like it Florida Georgia I don't
think click it can only met like three
dollar profit but some people buy a
charger at katies or maybe they're
bonding 20 chargers
so I'm trying to grab order totals based
on keyword clicks so i can really
monitor and see if it's being if it's
returning a profit and how we would go
about grabbing them total total sure so
there's two ways to do this arm easily
with Edwards number one if you are using
google analytics and the google has
already been modified to pull in your
shopping data then you can import those
values back to AdWords that requires a
little bit more work on the set up but
it gives you better holistic data the
simpler way to do it is are you using
the AdWords conversion script now I'm
not okay so so if you go on your average
account you go to the Tools menu and
there's a conversion tracking section
and you can fill out the form and
they'll give you the code um when you
look at it there is as a place for arm
order value and if you ask you have to
ask your shopping cart provider this
variable but a shopping cart checkout
page usually has a variable for total
cost of total sale amount cost of
shipping total cost of consumer you may
not have the shipping stuff depending
how you shipping but in stuff you asked
sure your host put your your shopping
our person what's the variable for my my
total value of that order and they
usually know this now they get this
question enough you can take that
variable you put it in the Edwards code
it's it's a copy paste and then put that
on your checkout page and then that
should grab on someone checks out they
your system fills in the variables for
what the consumer sees on the page
that's rendered since that variables
also in the code the code grabs it and
then pushes it back to AdWords so you
can see the actual revenue number from
the keyword the search query the add all
those good metrics inside your accounts
okay and that doesn't it the conversion
tracking yep yep and so it's an advanced
version implementation the conversion
tracking but
it's not a not a real hard change to
make thee the only trick really is
you're gonna have to ask your webmaster
or wherever makes your shopping cart
what that variable is uh it's a God who
stores so I'll need to know that Punjab
strength or whatever I grant see what
I'm told if it's a yahoo store okay so
it's been a little while since I've work
to be out here storage but they used to
have on the back and a place where you
could actually put in the conversion
tracking scripts within their interface
so it might be really simple that
integrationist aware ok so you fade it
out can you set one more time hey
Michael I can't heal anymore can you
yeah sorry Chris we can't hear you right
now if you type it in we might be able
to bring it up and we're going to move
on now and Ivan we've got your question
here and go ahead and ask it again hello
ah my question is what kind of display
network tab think you recommend for a
try like interest placements topics of
some combination probably what's your
spend how much you spend a month it's
like $20,000 if you have a where you
want to generate you generate traffic
yeah yeah it's a it's a in US market I'd
sing the health industry if you have a
flow of visitors to your site like the
very first thing that you should be
doing for Display Network targeting is
is the remarketing like that's that's
the low-hanging fruit there that you're
going to get 2 times the return on that
than any other targeting method you know
that they have to offer after that then
it's kind of like there's a bunch of
other targeting that
methoden see that you can try that they
won't be as good as remarketing because
you know it's the best predictor of you
know consumer behaviors it's a browsing
behavior like if if they're in the
market for something and they're looking
for it another that's a really strong
signal but beyond that there's a couple
other features that you potentially use
when it's called in market targeting and
similar audiences is a I think those
would be also effective but not not as
good as remarketing bread and then i
would go to either keywords or
placements or combination of both so
there's sites that regularly send you
get traffic placement arguments put ads
on the site so there's not then try
keywords is the most specific topics has
more volume than keywords but because
it's much broader it's got a higher CPA
so it's usually best to start with
keywords first then move to topics and
kind of go up the chain based upon these
have more volume but a higher CPA so
let's start with the best stuff first
and expand from there ok thank you yep
feels good all right actually Brad and
Larry thank you for staying over an
extra 15 minutes I know you both have
busy schedules for those of you who are
still with us your questions are
captured and here's what I'd recommend
if you have to leave us send a little
goodbye message in the
question-and-answer window tell us
something we could do better or
something that we did that was really
helpful we'll take a look at the
feedback I know that word stream is
going to reach out to all of you who've
attended here and so will market motive
if you have a question that was
unanswered try and pick it up with the
person who reaches back out to you I
know that market motive members can ask
these questions inside of the forums
where Brad answers directly as well as
Abhinav Kashyap and the rest of the gang
and I do want to encourage you as thanks
to larry for teaching with us today
please go check out his tools on word
stream com it's a great solution for SEM
analysis for those of you who have stuck
it out I do apologize we couldn't get
two questions there was literally
hundreds of questions coming and this
has been a great audience and we
appreciate the time that both Larry and
Brad have put in there are workshops
coming up for market loaded februari 11
to the social media workshop how your
Facebook
audience can be hit with targeted
campaigns and then februari 13 there's a
free workshop at market modem own
content marketing by Greg Jarboe visit
market modem com or reach out to us if
you'd like to attend one of those and
Gary they use words dream it rocks i
like and so I love the feedback it's
coming in Chris I guess there were seven
best practices and only captured five
we're going to make the slides available
to you and will reach out with a link so
you can check out on those other two
that Larry covered so with that any last
words I Larry for our audience as we
sign up I think I hear thanks yeah
there's a lot of fun I really appreciate
you coming with us yeah and i love the
comments coming and do take a moment
just to say farewell as you're leaving
both Brad and Larry you have organizer
status so please don't close down your
environment because some of the best
comments come in as people are taking
off and I'll go ahead and shut it down
after a few minutes here and then that
way we can have we can have comments to
send back out and both of our companies
can be responsive to this excellent
audience has been a lot of fun to
present to a Brad thinks much for your
work and answering here and you guys did
a great job ah thanks Michael almost a
pleasure to be on her alright good so
I'm going to go ahead and mute us and
just let the comments stream in and then
we'll send those out to you Larry as
well as the market motive team Hank